um so I'm going to talk about how to
operate so I've watched some of the
prior classes and I'm going to assume
that you've already sort of hired a
bunch of relentlessly resourceful people
that you built a product at least some
people love that you probably raised
some capital and now you're trying to
build a company so you're been forging a
product and now you've got a foreword to
a company and it actually argue forging
a company is much more difficult than
forging a product basic reason is people
are irrational so you probably all know
this either your parents your
significant other your brother or sister
your teacher somebody in your life is
irrational though their company's
basically taking all the irrational
people you know put him in one building
and then living with them 12 hours a day
at least
so it's very challenging now there's
techniques for coping with that and some
people get good at and some people don't
but that's where really what operating
is about so basically what you're doing
when you build a company is you're
building an engine and at first you have
a drawing literally on a whiteboard and
you're architecting it and it looks very
conceptually clean and beautiful and
pretty but when you start actually
translating it to practice you actually
it looks more like this and you're
holding it together with duct tape and
it takes a lot of heroic efforts of
people to actually hold it together
that's why people work 80 100 hours a
week is that heroic efforts is actually
necessary to keep this thing together
because you don't actually yet how
polish metal in place eventually you
want to construct a high performance
machine a machine that actually almost
nobody really has to worry about every
hour every minute and you know as we we
used to joke about eBay that if Martians
took over eBay it would take like six
months for the world to notice that's
what eventually what you want to get to
or is Warren Buffett says you know build
a company that idiots can run because
eventually they will so this is what you
want basically a performance machine
that idiots can run now as a leader what
is your real job what's your role
strictly speaking there's only one book
ever written that actually explains how
to do this it's a little old it's
written in 1982 by Andy Grove it's quite
famous and quite successful and his
definition of what your job is is to
maximize the output of an organization
your organization that you're
responsible for CEOs everything and a VP
you would be a part of the organization
and the organizations around you so if
you're a VP e you actually are
responsible for the performance of the
product team two or the marketing team
because you have influence there so this
is how you measure people and you want
to focus on the output not the input the
old adage about measuring not
during motion and confusing it out with
progress you're measuring only progress
and this is gonna sound like a fancy and
glamorous thing to do
maybe people get excited about managing
a whole large organization and being
responsible for the output but in
practice what you're gonna learn today
hopefully is that it's more about things
like ordering smoothies teaching your
receptionist how to answer the phone
properly and serving as a $10 an hour
TaskRabbit for your employees so let's
talk about that so at first when you
start a company everything is gonna feel
like a mess and it really should if you
have too much process too much
predictability you're probably not
innovating fast enough and creatively
enough so it should feel like every day
there's a new problem and what you're
doing is fundamentally triaging so some
things will look like a problem and
they're actually a cold they're just
gonna go away so somebody's annoyed
about this or that that may be a cold
and you shouldn't stress about it you
certainly shouldn't allocate a lot of
your time to it and some things are
gonna present themselves as colds but
just like in the emergency room if
they're not diagnosed properly they
actually can become fatal so I'm gonna
try to do is help give you a framework
for thinking about which things are
colds and which things are potentially
fatal so one of the most important
things I learned at square is actually a
concept of editing and this is I think
the best metaphor I've ever seen in like
14 years of running the stuff of how to
think about your job it's natural it's a
natural metaphor so it's easy to take
with you every day and actually it's
easy to transmit to each of your
employees so that they can figure out
whether they're editing or writing it's
a natural construct you generally know
when someone asks you to do something am
i more writing or am I more editing so
in editor is the best metaphor for your
job and we're talking about the specific
things you're doing in editing the first
thing an editor does and you've probably
all had this experience in school is you
submit a paper or to a TA a draft to
your friend the first thing in etre does
is they take out a red pen or nowadays
you know online and they start striking
things basically eliminating things the
most important task of an editor is to
simplify simplify simplify and that
usually means omitting things so that's
your job to is to clarify and simplify
for everybody on your team the more you
simplify the better people will perform
people cannot understand and keep track
of a complicated set of initiatives so
you've got to distill it down to one two
or three things and use a framework that
they can repeat they carry
Pete without thinking about the graffiti
to their friends they can repeat that
night don't accept the excuse of
complexity a lot of people will tell you
that well this is too challenging this
is too complicated well yeah I know
other people simplify but that's not for
me this is a complicated business
they're wrong you can change the world
in 140 characters you can build the most
important companies in history in a very
simple to describe concept you can
market products in less than about 50
characters there's no reason why you
can't build your company the same way so
force yourself to simplify every
initiative every product every marketing
every everything you do and and
basically take out that red and start
eliminating stuff second thing is what
editors do is they ask you clarifying
questions so when you present a paper to
somebody what do they usually do they
they find some ambiguity somewhere and
they say well do you really mean this do
you mean that you have an example of
this that's what your job is so you're
in a meeting and people are going to
look to you and the real thing you do is
you actually ask a lot of questions and
they can be simple basic questions like
should we try this seven days a week or
six days they can be fundamental
questions like where's our competitive
advantage here we try to do this
actually as investors to some investors
will ask you a billion questions about a
billion things and they'll have you do
diligence forever
we try to narrow down to one of the one
two or three four things that actually
matter for this company and only focus
on those things so it allows us to be
more decisive and we can make decisions
rapidly it allows us not to distract you
from your day job which is actually
building a company and yeah I think we
still get to the higher fidelity highest
fidelity answer because we don't have
all these extra extraneous pieces of
details and data now it's hard it's
something you have to practice but when
you're good good at it every step you
eliminate Andy Grove estimated that you
can improve performance by 30 to 50
percent the next thing you do is
allocate resources so the editing
construct this is what editors do all
the time
they take editors from the Mideast and
covering the Mideast and they move them
to Silicon Valley because Silicon
Valley's not now more interesting or
they move them to a sports section
because they want to compete on the
basis of sports with other journals and
other publications so that can be
top-down where I take a bunch of
allocate and resources in people it's
we're now going over here we're gonna
compete on this basis and then next
month next quarter next year I'd like
well that Middle East coverage is
getting boring a bland we don't want to
do that anymore let's go chase her for
something else or can be bottom up just
like journalists mostly come up with
their own stories the people who work
with you generally should be coming up
with their own initiatives so a reporter
will generally who covers Google come up
with the interesting stories that
they're hearing in the ether and propose
one or two to their editor for approval
but it's not like the editor is saying
go cover Google and this is the angle I
want once in a while they do that but
that's not the day the day the meat and
potatoes is what a journalist does every
day your goal over time is to actually
use less red ink every day so one way of
measuring how well you're doing and
communicating to your colleagues about
what's important what's not what why
something's are important some things
are not it's how much red ink you're
pulling out every day it's okay if you
have a bad day and the writings all over
the place but it's not okay if the
reading next month is more than it was
last month and that's quarters more than
this to measure yourself and how much
red ink you're creating the other thing
that's very important that actually
isn't as intuitive to a lot of people is
the job of an editor's to ensure a
consistent voice so if any of you read
The Economist you can tell that there's
one consistent voice you can pick up any
article any post in the Economist and it
fuels like it was written by the same
person ideally your company should feel
like on your website and your PR release
on your packaging of it's a physical
product anywhere on your recruiting
pages to feel like it was written by one
person that's extremely difficult to do
and at first you're gonna be tempted to
do that yourself which is okay for a
founder to do that him or herself
initially over time you do not want to
be doing all of the consistent voice
editing by yourself you want to train
people so they can recognize the
differences in voice so if you see this
website page it looks very different in
their recruiting page you start asking
questions why is that is the reporting
messed up is one of the leaders over
here not really understanding the voice
of the company so you gotta you have to
fix that over time but you want to start
with the objective of everything should
feel exactly the same it's quite quite
difficult in practice almost every
company has at least one piece of the
organization that isn't exactly on the
same voice at Apple which is know under
Steven under Steve's regime which was
notorious for getting this right if you
ask someone who worked at Apple talk ask
them about the internal tool
about recruiting do they really feel
like apple products all of them will
tell you no so you never a hundred
percent but you'd only want to get as
close to that as you can
the next complicated topic is delegating
so just like the other thing I like
about the metaphor of editing is writers
do most of the work in the world editors
are not actually writing most of the
content in any publication so that's
actually true of your company you are
not going to do most of the work you
shouldn't be doing most of the work and
the way you get out of doing most of the
work is you actually delegate now the
problem with delegating is that actually
you're responsible for everything so a
CEO founder there is no excuse there's
no like that's that department over
there this person over there screwed up
you're always responsible for every
single thing especially when things go
wrong so how do you both delegate but
not abdicate it's a pretty tricky
challenge and both are sins like if you
over delegate or and you abdicate or you
micromanage those are both sins so I'm
gonna give you a couple techniques for
solving this first this actually comes
from a high output management andy grove
is what's known as task relevant
maturity it's kind of a fancy phrase for
basically how's this person ever done
this before it's really simple how
mature is this person in doing something
and the more they've done the exact same
tasks before the more sort of rope
you're going to give them and the less
and the more they're trying something
new the more you're going to actually
instruct them and consistently
constantly regularly monitor so that's
kind of a basic concept but it's worth
keeping in the back of your brain the
interesting implication and this is
pretty radical is that any executive any
CEO should not have one management style
your management style actually needs to
be dictated by your employee so with one
particular person you may be very much a
micromanager because they're quite low
on this scale and with another person
you may be delegating a lot because
they're actually quite mature on this
scale so it's actually a good thing if
you do reference checks on somebody and
half the people you call stay there a
micromanager and the other half say they
actually give me a lot of responsibility
that's actually not a that's a that's a
feature not a bug I didn't understand
that at first at all like I used to be
befuddled when people would do reference
checks on me and come back with his like
complicated mosaic and basically finally
figured out that maybe I was actually
doing my job correctly so then of course
tell other people that this the way to
do it
a more nuanced answer though that I've
sort of came up with it's how do you
make decisions and delegating first
doing it yourself you don't want to do
it yourself too often
so what elf cases we borrowed from Peter
is my first two-by-two matrix
ever in my life but if you taught me
something at least is you basically sort
your own level of conviction about a
decision on a grid you know extremely
high extremely low there's times when
you know something's a mistake and
there's times where you wouldn't do it
that way but you have no real idea what
the whether whether it's the right or
wrong answer and then there's a
consequence to mention there are things
that if you make the wrong decision are
actually catastrophic to your company
and you will fail there are things that
are pretty low impact that really at the
end of the day aren't going to make a
big difference at least initially so
what I basically believe is that where
there's low consequences and you have
very low confidence in your own opinion
you should absolutely delegate and
delegate completely let people make
mistakes and learn on the other side
obviously where the consequences are
extremely dramatic and you have
extremely high conviction that you're
right you actually can't let your junior
colleague like make a mistake you're
ultimately responsible for that mistake
and if it's really important you just
can't allow that to happen now the best
way to do that is to actually explain
your thinking the why it's easy to
shortcut when you get busy explaining
whys of the world but it's very
important to try when I was at LinkedIn
I had a colleague who's quite quite
talented but occasionally would get
annoyed if I didn't exactly agree with
his opinion on something and so I spent
a lot of time trying to persuade him
why I was making a decision in a certain
way and his wild card the card he would
ultimately call out if I didn't quite
persuade and was he's like okay you're
the boss and that meant to me like I was
burning a lot of social capital every
time he said that I knew I was like
really creating a thin line and that
ultimately that was gonna backfire if I
did that too often so you want to track
the times that you're doing that an
example this is squares one of my
favorite people in the world and my
second hire first marketing hire had
this program he wanted to run called
inner square which basically allowed
people to give out square merchants to
get out ten other squares to their call
its imagine a food truck outside put
like ten squares on the couch
and people could just grab them and Kyle
had this great idea this would be an
awesome marketing program squares would
spread squares to other people and you
know to some extent it was on brand so
didn't have catastrophic consequences
each of these ten squares didn't cost
that much money so financially we could
afford to do it but at that time my 10
years of experience said there's just no
way this is gonna work in a meaningful
enough scale to move our metrics enough
and I actually would prefer we don't not
do this but Kyle was so excited about
this that I decided to just let him do
it he learned that actually when you
measure this thing it's not massive it
doesn't create like massive value for
the company it did require a fair amount
of operational complexity to ship all
these squares to people and figure out
how to get them squares etc but it
allowed him to be excited about his job
and to learn how to filter future ideas
so it's totally worth letting him make
the quote/unquote mistake the next and
most possibly most important thing to do
is actually edit the team so these are
the people that you work with and
nobody's going to have a perfect team
and you're certainly not going to start
that way so would I'm gonna try to do is
maximize the probability for success in
editing the team so I like this idea of
barrels and ammunition so most companies
once they get into hiring mode as Sam
pointed out you should defer that for a
while but once you do they just hire a
lot of people and they're like expect
and you expect that as you add people
your throughput your horsepower your
velocity of shipping things is going to
increase it turns out it doesn't work
that way usually when you hire more
engineers you actually don't get that
much more done you actually sometimes
get less done you hire more designers
you definitely don't get more done you
get less done per day we're gonna talk
about why but so the reason why is that
most people most great people even are
actually ammunition but what you need in
your company are barrels and you can
only shoot through the number of unique
barrels you have so that's how the
velocity of your company improves is by
adding barrels and then you stock them
with ammunition and then you can do a
lot so if you go from one barrel company
which is mostly how you start to a two
barrel company suddenly you get twice as
many things done per day per week per
quarter if you're gonna three barrels
great if you go to four battles awesome
barrels are incredibly difficult to find
but when you have them like give them
lots of equity
about them take them to dinner every
week because they're virtually a like
irreplaceable because they're also very
culturally specific so a barrel one
company may not be a barrel on another
company because one of the ways the
definition of a barrel is they can take
an idea from conception all the way
through shipping and bring people with
them and that's a very culturally
specific opportunity a specific skillset
rather so two questions probably are
occurring to you is how do you figure
out who's a barrel and who's not
one is you start actually with a very
small set of responsibilities it can be
fairly trivial it can be something like
I want to reward the engineers that are
in my office at 9 o'clock at night every
night with a nice cold fresh smoothie
this is actually a real example I was
frustrated our engineers were working
really hard at square and you know maybe
20% to 30% would stay very late into the
evening and I wanted to sort we all
ready to serve them dinner but I wanted
to give them something cool to reward
them you could think about alcohol but
that's a little complicated so smoothies
were probably a little bit better than
the pizza which drains you of energy but
nobody could get smoothies in my office
to show up at 9 o'clock sharp that were
cold that tasted good and delivered in
the right place that engineers would
find them you think this is simple but
in fact it's like two months to get this
right so that we had an intern start and
I think on a second day I was explaining
this problem and he said well I'll do it
and it's like looking at him like
there's no way you have seen my office
manager fail my assistant fail all who
are actually pretty good this isn't
gonna happen and then lo and behold that
night they show up on time cold
delivered the right place and my first
instinct was great not not nothing about
the smoothies but okay now I can
actually give him something more
important and consequential or
complicated to do and that's what you
will actually want to do with every
single employee every single day is
expand the scope of the responsibilities
until it breaks and it will break
everybody like I couldn't run the world
like everybody has like some level of
complexity that they can handle and what
you want to do is keep expanding it
until you see where it breaks and that's
the role that they should stay in that
level of sophistication but some people
will surprise you there will be people
who you don't expect without with
different backgrounds without a lot of
experience that just can handle enormous
ly complicated tasks and so keep testing
that and pushing the envelope the other
signal to look for
once you've hired someone is with an
open office just watch who goes up to
other people's desks particularly people
that they don't report to if people
start going to your desk someone
individual employees desk and they don't
report to them it's a sign that they
believe that that person can help them
so if you see that consistently those
are your barrels just promote them give
them more opportunity as fast as you can
the other question everybody asks about
people is when do you hire somebody
above somebody and when do you sort of
mentor somebody or when do you need to
replace somebody and the way the way to
think about this is every company has
its own growth rate and every individual
has their own growth rate so some
companies that are very successful let's
say LinkedIn LinkedIn was always a very
linear company it never went like this
so for example I joined LinkedIn 18
months after we launched and we had only
1.5 million users which in the social
product is very small number and when I
joined I was the 27th employee when I
left two and a half years later later we
only had 57 employees in contrast when I
joined square is the 20th employee two
and a half years later we had like 250
300 employees so each company has its
own velocity on this curve and if the
company is going like this you could
only keep people on the roles that their
own personal learning curve is going
like this on the other hand if the
company's growing like this anybody
whose learning curve is faster than that
you can keep giving them the same role
to do so always track like the
individual slope of an employee and the
company's growth rate now that you have
your barrels identified so you're to
pick out the people that can really take
an idea that you have in the back your
head yeah scope it out run with it make
it happen ship it and it's perfect where
do you aim these barrels so I'm gonna
argue that you really need to spending a
lot of time focusing people this is
something I've learned from Peter teal
actually he used to insist at PayPal
that every single person could only do
exactly one thing and we all rebelled
every single person the company rebelled
to this idea because it's so unnatural
it's so different than every other
company where people wanted to do
multiple things and especially to get
more senior you want to definitely want
to do multiple things and you're like
you feel it's like insulting to be asked
to do just one thing and Peter would
enforce this pretty strictly he
basically say I will not talk to you
about anything else except this one
thing I've assigned to you I don't want
to hear about how great you're doing
over here like
shut up Pierre would run away and then
focused until you conquer this one
problem and the insight behind this is
that most people will solve problems
that they understand how to solve
roughly speaking they will solve B plus
problems instead of a plus problems a
plus problems are high-impact problems
for your company but they're difficult
you don't wake up in the morning with a
solution so you tend to procrastinate
them so imagine you wake up in the
morning you create a list of things to
do today
there's usually the eight plus one on
the top of the list but you never get
around to it and so you solve the second
and third and have over an entire
company of hundreds of people that just
Cascades so you have a company that's
always solving B plus things which does
mean you grow and doesn't mean you add
value but you never really create that
breakthrough idea because no one is
spending a hundred percent of their time
banging their head against the wall
every day until they solve it
so I highly recommend some version of
that you can be less stringent you can
be like you can get three things to work
on but there I would still track at
least the concept of what would happen
if you only gave everybody one thing to
prioritize now because you can't make
decisions you don't want to be making
all these decisions yourself you have to
create tools that enable people to make
decisions at the same level ideally a
fidelity that you would make them
yourself so how do you create scale and
leverage first thing I'd recommend is
building a dashboard this is an old
square dashboard it actually looks
pretty presentable even today the the
construct of a dashboard first of all
should be drafted by the founder you
need to basically simplify the value
proposition in the company's metrics for
success on a whiteboard you can have
other people build the dashboard I don't
actually care about that but you need to
draw it out like what does business
success look look to us and what are the
key inputs to those and then have
someone create something that is very
intuitive for every single person in the
company including customer support to
use and then the key metric of whether
you succeeded is what fraction of your
employees use that dashboard every day
if it's actually useful it should be
close to a hundred percent it's not
going to be probably a hundred percent
but you want to measure that just like
you have quality scores for all your
other KPIs with users the dashboard
needs to be as intuitive as it is as
your product is for users
other things wait hold on yeah let's go
back one second another concept is
transparency and people will often
that's weird okay
transparency people talk a lot about
it's kind of a goal that everybody
ascribes to but when push comes to shove
very few people actually adhere to it so
let me let me walk through a little bit
of transparency in different stages of
transparency metrics are the first step
so everybody in your company absolutely
should have access to every single thing
that's going on other things that I like
to do are take your board decks and as
you get more formal the board decks will
get more complicated and actually review
every single slide with every single
employee after the board meeting you can
strip out the compensation information
if you really want to but every other
slide you should go through with the
entire employee base and explain it and
if you can't remember some of the
feedback you got from your board that's
really cool to pass on another thing we
did at square is your company's skills
everybody's not going to get invited to
every meeting but they're gonna want to
go to every meeting the way you scale
that is you create notes for every
meeting and you send it to the entire
company so we created a notes at Elias
for every single meeting involving more
than two people someone would write
notes and send it to the entire company
so people felt like as the company added
employees they can continue to monitor
and track what was interesting what was
going on and he never felt excluded
hopefully the other thing is like even
like details around conference rooms
every conference room at square has
glass walls because as soon as you have
regular walls people wonder what's going
on it's amazing like if they can see
who's actually in the meeting and who's
meeting with who when they don't start
they don't worry nearly as much as
what's going on behind those closed
doors stripe you may have seen a blog
post but I think Patrick wrote it about
email transparency about actually
allowing everybody to have access to
email that's pretty far out there but
it's actually got interesting you know
sort of merits to it I would all call
the tactics that you've read about here
about it's sort of minimal viable
transparency I actually think you could
push the envelope a lot more Steve Jobs
tried this at next he actually tried
transparent compensation
I actually think although next didn't do
extremely well it wasn't the real reason
wasn't because of the experiment around
compensation transparency and that
there's a lot of merit to that and you
know the critique of like compensation
transparency is often well we want
people to be teammates and work together
and collaborate
and if you look in the sports world
though where people are actually
teammates and they do have to
collaborate all of their compensations
completely public in fact each of us can
look up anybody's compensation in the
sports world they get it exactly
accurate and somehow it seems to work so
I'm not totally bought into the idea
that you need to keep transfer
compensation non-transparent that
finally metrics so you want to measure
things you want to measure outputs not
inputs and again you should dictate this
yourself you should draft the dashboard
to tie this all together one important
concept I want to note is pairing
metrics or pairing indicators which is
if you measure one thing and only one
thing the company tends to optimize to
that and often at the expense of
something else that's important a
classic example in payments and
financial services is around risk it's
really easy to give the risk team the
objective and say we want to lower our
fraud rate it sounds great until they
start treating every single user in this
audience as a suspect user because they
want to lower their fraud rate so they
require each of you to call them up on
the phone and give them more
supplemental information and facts in
things and the of the lowest fraud rate
in the world you also have the worst you
know sort of customer satisfaction score
so what you want to measure at the same
time as your fraud rate is your false
positive rate that forces the team to
actually innovate similarly you can give
recruiters metrics around hiring and
guess what you'll have a lot of people
come in through interviews but if you're
not tracking the quality of hires you
may be very unhappy with the quality of
people you're interviewing are the
people you're giving offers to so you
always want to create the opposite as an
indication and measure both and the
people who are responsible for that team
need to be measured on both finally
around metrics one insight I've had over
my career is what you you kind of want
to look for the anomalies you don't
actually want to look for the expected
behavior so that a famous example was at
PayPal none of the top ten markets that
the company was planning to go after
included eBay but one day someone
noticed that 50 for power sellers had
actually hand written into their eBay
listings please pay me with PayPal and
brought this to the attention of the
executive team at the time the first
reaction of the executive team was what
the hell's going on let's kick them out
of the system that's not our focus
fortunately I think David Sox came back
the next day and said I think we found
our market let's actually build tools
for these power sellers instead
forcing them to write into their listing
pay me with paypal why don't we have an
HTML button that they can just insert
well that started at work and then he
said well actually why don't we make
them insert it why why should we make
them inserted all the time why don't we
just automatically inserted for them so
they can insert it once and then every
single listing they have forever you
know this automatically appear there so
that became the success for PayPal
similarly I was that LinkedIn and I saw
this stat that made no sense to me the
UI of the site was a little bit
different back then but 25% of all
clicks maybe 30% of all clicks from the
homepage were people going to their own
profile and that made no sense
whatsoever I mean they say it was a
setting that's like you have to
literally go to the right margin final
link and it was 25 to 30% of every
single click at scale I mean so this is
like statistically valid stuff and it
made no sense whatsoever I never never
have seen like a UI performed that way
and I kind of went around for weeks
trying to figure this out and then
someone very smart actually as Max
Levchin said something to me it was like
he's like it's vanity and I'm like aha
people are looking at themselves in the
mirror that's a pretty good answer so
because they weren't editing their
profile that nobody has like something
to edit every day and their profile but
they actually were just looking at
themselves in the mirror every day cuz
it made him feel good and then you could
actually test that hypothesis and say
well if I have more content do I look at
myself in the mirror we're off and turns
out you did if you had more endorsements
did you look at yourself in the mirror
more often turns out you did so we
actually figured out like what was
actually underneath utilitarian product
that the product team thought they were
building was actually a lot of emotional
vanity they didn't exactly translate it
to the best possible feature like the
PayPal example which you couldn't easily
put a button said be more vain today you
know on the home page that would
probably not work perfectly so it never
really like took off the way the PayPal
example did but it really clarified what
the user what users of the product
really wanted and we wouldn't have found
that without looking for anomalous data
the final topic I want to talk about is
details and there's a sign reading
there's a great book I really like by
Bill Walsh called the score takes care
of itself and the basic point of the
book is that if you get all the details
right you don't worry about how to build
a billion-dollar business how to have a
hundred million dollars or revenue how
to have a billion users that's a
byproduct of getting all the details of
what you do every day could be axial
so the example he talks about in the
book that really resonated with me was
he took over the 49ers in 1979 they were
the worst team in football I believe
they were two and fourteen the year
before which is really bad for those of
you don't know football in the next ten
years he managed to transform the team
into the NFL's Bass won three Super
Bowls and what's the first thing he did
to start going from a terrible team to
the best team ever in many ways he
actually taught the receptionist's how
to answer the phone properly
he wrote a three page memo about how to
actually answer the phone
now that may sound absurd but his point
was if the organization as a whole does
everything exactly the right way then
receivers for example will start running
their routes at seven-and-a-half yards
not seven yards not eight yards and that
actually will matter and that everybody
on the team execute exactly up to the
same standard of performance you'll have
a organization that is performing at the
highest possible level and then with
enough random variation the highest
possible performance team will do the
high the best so the way you translate
this to a company are to a lot of
details that may not matter they may not
seem that they might are superficially
most people would agree about it details
matter when it when it faces the user
but where the real debate is on things
that don't face the user so Steve Jobs
famously in the Mac insisted upon an
immaculate circuit design board you can
read about this in various books the Mac
for those of you don't remember the Mac
probably everybody here but some of you
may have seen it I actually couldn't be
opened so the circuit board design
couldn't be seen by any single person in
the world there was no way to open the
Mac except that people who worked at
Apple and Steve insisted that it be
absolutely perfect and beautiful that's
the kind of detail obsession that this
sort of philosophy of building a company
requires examples that may be more
practical for you instead of circuit
boards are things like what food do you
serve people it's actually matters more
than you might guess when people don't
like the food you serve them what do
they do they go gossip they go complain
to their friends they go walk over to
someone's desk and all the sudden at
lunch what they're complaining about is
it they're mostly spending time
gossiping and complaining instead of
brainstorming so you don't have this
serendipitous like idea matching another
serendipitous idea that creates a spark
instead they're all wandering and
willing around so the best thing you can
do is actually give people the food they
want or food that's good for them that
makes them more productive so
seem a lot like this glorious job you
thought you have it's actually more like
running around being a task rabbit for
people but it's to take the things off
their plate that are a distraction so
they can be high-performance machines
and if you take enough things away from
people that distract them and give them
the tools to be successful all of a
sudden your organization produces a lot
more similarly another example that's
often got wrong is office space so one
natural instinct is when you need an
office you just have an office manager
or someone on your team gonna find
offices and they'll go on tours with a
chance they'll come back with photos and
ideas you need to do that yourself the
office environment that people live in
and work in every day dictates your
culture and help you will make decisions
it dictates how hard people work there's
almost no important more decision other
than what company you're gonna be then
what's the office environment you're
actually in and most people don't do
that and then the final thing and then
I'll take some questions is around
effort ultimately I don't believe that
you can build a company without a lot of
effort and that you'd need to lead by
example so Bill Walsh the first chapter
of his book is get gets asked this
question of how do you know whether
you're doing her job and this is the
answer he gives coaches that used to ask
them that question so if this is what
you feel like every day you're probably
on the right track and if that doesn't
sound appetizing you probably shouldn't
start a company truthfully all right
with that I'm done with the prepared
part let me see if anybody has questions
I could try to be helpful with any
questions yes I would I would do in
probably bands you can do it either just
everybody the company gets paid the same
or you can have like all discipline all
engineers or you could do it by
experience like extremely the way Steve
did it actually at next was there's a
high ban and a low ban and you've had a
lot of experience or a little experience
and those in solo band back then you
know now would probably be like $85,000
kind of everybody just flatly gets paid
eighty five thousand and if your super
experience ever gets paid like one
hundred thirty thousand and that's just
it like this sort of the next translated
for inflation
you'd be amazed well yes so the question
was a besides food while they're kind of
details do people care about the laptops
they use I mean this is now the default
that everybody has but five years ago it
was a benefit to give people high
quality machines as opposed to
optimizing our costs and having Dell
machines and ugly monitors just as an
example so if you think about all these
people that are relentlessly resourceful
incredibly talented in a massively
competitive ecosystem competing for
talent you want to give the people the
best possible tools to do the best
possible job and so right rigorously
thinking through how do I make people
more successful what things do they not
need to be working on that are
distracting and what things can I
actually give them that make them more
valuable per day and then just break
that down every day and solve that stuff
yourself it's a good question I actually
think that you should start first of all
you must have your own office
I don't believe ever in shared office
spaces Peter talks a little bit about
this that every startup every good
startup is a cult and it's really hard
to create a cult if you're sharing space
with people because that cult means that
you think you're better than everybody
else in the world you have a special way
of doing things that's different than
everybody else in the world and if
you're sharing physical space with
people it's very hard to inculcate that
so I would start there but it is a
prioritization question that when we
have every every company on scare us
resources just a question of magnitude
like how many zeros are you paying
attention to you know probably not $10
expenditures but $100 then thousand
dollars and 10,000 then a million then
ten million starts being a rounding
error so what I would do is figure out
like what's most important in a high
quality office that creates a good vibe
that allows you to recruit people
because recruits are very savvy about
this they walk into your office and they
can tell a lot about the culture
instantly I said I walk in a company
office and I can tell often whether I'm
gonna invest shoes I walk in like I
could absolutely school things out that
I just don't want to invest in as soon
as I walk in and there's times walking
the office is like wow this is really
impressive you can tell how people work
together how hard they're working how
distracted they are roll off boat at
Sequoia I made a point to me about
YouTube so when I invested in YouTube
but very very beginning it wasn't
obviously going to be successful and
then roll-off led this series a
investment for Sequoia in YouTube and we
were on a board meeting together and he
said you know I think YouTube's really
gonna work and I said why and said well
every time I go to one of my portfolio
companies half the office is watching
YouTube at lunch and that's like a
pretty good sign I'm still like you pick
up on these little things you can
predict a lot boy yeah so the question
is how's the best way to green gain
street cred for a new manager almost all
good managers in Silicon Valley are
promoted because of their individual
performance and cultures that are
meritocratic you know the percentage is
even higher so we tried at PayPal to
only promote people that were basically
kicking ass at their discipline so Peter
didn't believe in general managers in
fact I remember going for a jog around
campus within my first week at PayPal
and he's asking me you know how things
going the usual kind of CEO questions
and then we got this debate about
whether the company needed any managers
and he's like nope no managers we're
only going to promote people so the VP
of engineering is going to be the single
best engineer the VP of designs in a
single best designer the VP
approximately single best product person
and they're gonna learn to manage later
and the advantage of that is you don't
have you don't demoralize people because
everybody knows that their boss actually
is better at their job than they are and
they can learn stuff and you can learn a
little bit of the management techniques
later as opposed to promoting people who
are just good people managers that don't
actually have the discipline and skill
and that does demoralize people so I
think just being excellent at something
and then getting excellent at getting a
bunch of people to do something as the
next task but people people you just
have to learn some things you have to
learn about doing you can't learn to
play the guitar by reading a book you've
actually got to try to manage a bit and
you won't do it well I have another sort
of set of tactics and classes on what
you actually do when you transition from
a manager individual contributor to
manager and it's hard one of the first
things people don't get right is their
time allocation and so actually I would
recommend doing what I call calendar or
audit in tracking for a month what do
you spend your time on and how much is
managing and editing how much is writing
etc and then optimize that over time
you can get a mentor find somebody who's
been a manager before that will work
with you not your boss because your boss
has a set of complicated objectives
including how much are we shipping a
mentor can just focus on you and making
you more successful yeah so I would look
at every piece of copy in every
department
so like another area that almost never
is they've done so look at the
recruiting website almost never done to
the same quality is your conversion
funnel let's look at customer support
another classic area that isn't up to
the same quality in crete customer
support like a product so that you
actually have an engineering team a
design team over time they actually
focuses on making that world-class
usually where you have different
executives a scaled company most
executives we're trained differently at
different companies and they bring some
of that with them so you've got a cross
train that so if you've hired a VP of
engineering from Google it's very
different than a design leader came from
Apple they don't actually learn how to
do anything the same way so you're gonna
have to stitch that together somehow
either one or the other is gonna have to
learn and the other style or gonna have
to create your own style and really
teach that to your executives so it
shows up all the time but you all you
all you need to do is just pick up the
company's products and look for things
that have a different voice and you can
see it visual voice word choice all over
the map Sam so the canonical advice and
this now sounds obvious but actually was
pretty radical in 1982 when Andy wrote
for his book is you should have a
one-on-one roughly every two weeks
some people say every week and I don't
think you want to go longer than two
weeks one week can be ideal actually in
many companies the reason why in fact
there's an old another adage which is
you should only have five to seven
direct reports that actually derives
from the concept of a one-on-one every
week so that the direct reports so that
you can fit enough one-on-ones in your
calendar and still get other things done
so I think one-on-ones per week or a
good idea the agenda should be crafted
by the employee who reports to the
manager not the manager the one-on-one
is mostly for the benefit of the
employee so they should walk in with
here's the three or four things I want
to talk about ideally they circulate
that you can be even bullet points in
advance by email but in advance you have
time to chew on it and you're not on the
fly winging your responses but that's
probably the best structure now if
someone's really good and really
talented and it's been doing something
for a long time with a lot of internal
credibility you might push out the one
every week and relax that to one every
two weeks possibly once a month I don't
know that I would go beyond once a month
ever yeah so the question is when when
do you compromise hire more ammunition
and sort of a barrel truthfully you're
gonna hire more ammunitions by by
definition than you aren't barrels so
there's a ratio between the two the
question is the ratio so at some point
the ratio is going to get out of but
whack so if you're the only barrel on
the company you have 50 engineers you
might as well only have 10 engineers
because you're not gonna get any more
done so you're just wasting resources
you got frustrated engineers because
everybody's going to need your approval
your sign-off your editing it's just
going to stock and frustrate people so
it's really no different disciplines
engineering like I actually think like
roughly one to ten to twenty it's
probably about the right range like you
know you don't need you don't need more
engineers until you have more barrels
designer is a little different but it
doesn't it's always going to be hiring
more munitions and they good leader or a
good barrel will kind of have a feel for
that so one way - one way to correct for
this natural tendency is to increase
that your head count on your team like
sort of an empire building tendency like
oh so I'm at just 20 people and Sam only
manages 10 and you manage three so I'm
more important than Sam and you're more
important than you one way to do that is
you put an X here of the number of
people that the output sorry specify how
how many things they've done
successfully and then divide by the
number of people on their team and tell
them that this is going to be their
grade in their performance review
shockingly this wide doesn't start
increasing on that team it's amazing how
this works and be really explicit about
it
so this how often you intervene this or
for the photo companies and what's your
people so how often do I need weather
yeah the question is for venture
capitalists how often do I interact with
my companies meet with them generally
when we invest and we do do some seed
investments where we a lot that's less
money but when we invest a fair amount
of money and lead around like a Series A
Series B round we joined the board and
roughly I meet with the founder CEO
every two weeks that's the default now
there can be obviously there's
inflection moments and things go right
go well or wrong and that you know
that's on an ad-hoc basis these days
actually surprisingly I do a lot by text
message I even have one CEO who
snapchats me all the time like I've
actually rather not but that so the
world the world has changed a lot but I
try in-person meetings every two weeks
no I mean really it's like being a
venture capitalist is more to me like
being a psychologist so if you come to
my office you'll see actually we have
two chairs kind of a raid like this with
a little table in the middle and we sit
down and I'm basically like so tell me
your problems you know it's like a
question it's like so have you and then
in there my response is usually well
have you thought about this have you
talked to this person have you tried
this etc and it's just asking a lot of
questions and going back that way but
that's 90% of what I do well depends on
where your prioritizations are so you
know Sam talked a little bit about this
in his lecture but every company will
move recruiting you know first second or
third somewhere and that yeah sort of
spectrum it was your number one priority
then about 25% is probably a pretty good
allocation actually I like the calendar
audit for CEOs even more so than for new
managers so when I work with CEO is
sometimes who aren't thriving in that
role for the first time I actually force
them to show me their calendar and
before I do that and now I'm going to
ruin this trick because I want to tell
you it to you I actually asked them to
rank their priorities write them down on
a piece of paper and there's just
specify whatever they are then we go to
pull up their calendar and see if it
matches and it
never matches like never like recruiting
is the one that's most often awry so you
know let's say half the CEOs you meet
with no safe recruiting are boring party
it's almost never the biggest block of
time on anybody's calendar and so that's
what you're trying to do is match
resources and inputs against priorities
and a calendar on an a4 so there's no
software that does this really well it'd
be great like actually we literally pull
up someone's Google Calendar kind of
manually add up the hours which is in
someone insane but that's that's the
best way it's just more of your parties
if your priorities and raising money you
don't want to allocate a hundred percent
of time to recruiting you want to
allocate a fair amount of time to
raising money for that block of time
anybody okay good question I think the
way to harmonize the question is really
how do you harmonize things like where
details can really matter but you only
get one thing you know to do and you've
got to allocate to the top one two or
three things how do you how do you put
those two things together and actually
there is some tension and even in a
healthy organization there's some
tension of like why are we actually
focused on you know writing the script
as opposed to something a user may see I
think the underlying philosophy of
getting the details right is pretty
important to install in the very very
very beginning of a company because
people will start acting that way making
decisions that way themselves so you
won't have to actually literally do that
and if you have to do that it actually
shows that yet the foundation isn't
actually that that solid so if when you
first start the company it's about
getting the details right that everybody
is precise everybody on every task is
always thinking that way and then that
skills and then the people you bring in
it's a little self-fulfilling people who
can think that way will tend to get
hired people can't won't get hired each
team in each leader will tend to enforce
that themselves so CEO is almost never
doing it so it's partially like how do
you start
and it cultures like that I mean that
the key to culture is it's a rule it's a
framework for making decisions and if
you have a cultures baked people learn
how to make decisions across that
culture and you're never saying anything
you never have to really do anything
except just yeah
watch and you know and promote and move
people around cool well I guess that's
it thank you
[Applause]
you